today say you said I'm gonna go train
and I'm gonna go bring the coaches and
I'm gonna do real training like you know
how you go at certain people like hey
did mazaval really train this for go up
against this yeah he was really oh this
dispatcher that guy really wasn't
training no [ __ ] he lost why didn't he
only do one week of training you kind of
process that right say you go and three
to six months you fully prepare to fight
okay and say there is a fight with you
against Conor or against khabib those
two names if a fight was with you
against Conor at their age today and say
khabiba green and said he wants to come
back we know it's not going to happen he
said he's not going to do it because
when his father died he promises mom
that he's not going to come back and
you're saying 100 you're not going to do
it even for 30 million dollars you say
you would do 400 million dollars right
now for no no no no but but if if it did
and you did train we know it's not going
to happen but if it did do you think you
could beat a Connor or a khabib today if
you did go six months training and they
did as well but if I have the the the
same the motivation to do do it yeah I
believe so even I have to say do you
think you can beat
if I have the motivation to go to
another Earth and you don't want to do
it
no I don't want to do it I I don't want
to have the heart I don't want to have
the motivation of the way you were you
and you were kind of tying in the age
factor with the motivation I don't think
it's the age though it's not the fight
guys it's I don't want to take yeah the
beating
two months of my life getting I don't
want to waste too much of my life
doing this I just don't want to put me
through the stress through the the the
the the grind of doing this I guess do
you want to be in the hunt for another
thing in your life again or you're done
being in there oh yeah what are you on
the hunt for like hunt at that level of
a hunt I'm a as a human being and I'm
sure you guys is the same for you I
the key form is to be happy is to to
reach the to be the person that I want
to be and and I remember when I was a
kid I was looking at myself in the
mirror
and I didn't I did not like what I used
to see I hate it I don't I didn't like
myself and I was a kid at that time I
was bullied
I was a kid who lacked a lot of
self-confidence and then I had a good
image of myself
and I I remember
that I had a vision
and and I had a vision of who I wanted
to become not I'm not talking about
champion and and physical so I'm talking
about about mental like as a person
and I fall in love with that image that
I want to become
so that's what
helps me to get to to go through my day
at the time when it was hard for me at
the time because I didn't have the
knowledge that I that I have now
and I'm still not that person that
perfect ideal person that I want to
become you know I'm better than I was
but I'm still lacking a lot of a lot of
thing you know for example I'm not a
very patient person I'm more patient
that I used to be but I'm not you know
things like this that the the idea
person that I visualized when I was a
kid and it changed over the year I'm
still not there I still you know I want
to become that person I'm still working
towards it and I'm not talking about
championship and stuff like this just
helped me to become more confident
changing it's bigger than fighting yes
exactly it's better just be the human
the person yeah now I'm more I'm more of
an entrepreneur and more you know it's
different my life has changed but it
mold me to become a different person and
I'm I'm still not there yet I'm still
working to become that person but are
you in a hunt for something outside of
that I mean I understand because even in
life one can be in the hunt for what
you're doing like I as a man I am in the
hunt to really be curious to know what
the 50 year old pbd is going to be I'm
43 right now I can't wait to meet my 50
year old Patrick David I want to see
what I'm gonna be like I'm so excited to
meet that guy I'm patient the next seven
years it can go as slow as possible I'm
cool with it but I'm excited about it
right I'm looking forward to it because
I want to see what next develop and I'm
gonna have as I recreate myself but I'm
talking about outside of that
you know are you in the hunt for
something a sport a business like khabib
is doing what he's doing Eddie Hearn and
Jake Paul are sitting there Eddie's
telling JK you're an average boxer at
best but that's still a compliment and
Jake so they're in the hunt for
something you know Dana's in the hunt
for something Joe is in the hunt for
something he's in a podcast game and
he's doing what he's doing right
everybody's in the hunt for something
what are you in the hunt for right now I
believe I
I'm in the aunt to to first to be
healthy this thing is the most I think
to be in order to be happy one of the
most important thing is to be to be
healthy
to be loved to be the love the the
health I think it's part of happiness
and freedom whenever 100 free you know
we always have responsibility and
for me I use
fighting as a benchmark to to have more
freedom to to be able to do what I what
I do
and I'm still not satisfied yet you know
what I mean I'm still working to be more
free to be have more and when I say
freedom it's not necessarily money money
help you to be free because you you you
can buy things and something you can
have a better lifestyle you know a
quality of life through it but that's
not the only thing that makes you happy
you know what I mean and I think that's
what it is and and I have knowledge that
I have now that I'm glad that I have but
I wish I would have had before you know
what I mean stuff I've learned that
changed my life that man I
there's so much stuff like like I wish I
would have you know what I'm asking
though do you know what I'm asking you
know what I'm asking do you know what
I'm asking like here's what I'm asking
like I'm asking I I is there a space not
personal not like Enlightenment which is
I mean we're all searching Enlightenment
because we want to get a little bit more
clarity in Life or free to making more
money but are you because again you're
41 and you're very young right are you
are you in the hunt to give your best to
like for example are we gonna see a GSP
podcast coming out and that's what
you're gonna do for the next few years
because you want to build a podcast and
you want to go out today is it going to
be you know what I I like what uh uh
Dana is doing I feel like I can give
back to the UFC World by doing XYZ I
feel like I can go out there and do
build one of the best training
facilities where young Fighters come and
I shape their mindset and I develop one
of the best schools around the world to
teach trainer to teach Fighters how to
really fight what's that next thing with
you I for me I think
it would be to to pass down my knowledge
you know knowledge uh that I acquire
over the years
um
in order to help
the Next Generation to to get better to
surpass the present generation
and um I think it's Einstein he says if
I
if I'm if I can see further than my
predecessor is because I I'm standing on
shoulder of giant and it's I think it's
true in sport as well
I I think what I can do to help the next
generation is in a way
for me I'm working now on a project with
doing instructional video I'm gonna
that's one thing I'm gonna do and I'm
gonna be able to to teach my knowledge
to to to certain people that can that it
will help them to not make the same
mistake that I did yeah so they they
have a head start already so that that's
why when you talk about for example
Sport and performance and business
anything
why performance get better it's not
because the guy is better it's because
they have a head start they learn from
their predecessors and I think it's the
same thing in everything and and I think
it's my duty in order to try to help
them to make the world better to to to
to pass down that knowledge who do you
think how I am able to sometimes I
mentally a lot of guy after they retire
they they become kind of depressed
because they don't have that high
anymore how I overcome that you know I
use fasting and cold and water immersion
to to through this and people are like
ah it's kind of stupid but it's not
stupid in a way you can explain yeah
sometimes in life some people like they
feel depressed or or you know they have
some problems everybody has problems
even if you don't have that much of a
problem you might feel like you have a
lot of problem but one thing that
helps me
with
fasting and cold water immersion is
these
I put myself voluntary into that stress
when you haven't eat for a certain
amount of days and if you try that to
ask your doctor first for me I helped me
mentally it's very therapeutic
because
when you have a need for a certain
amount of days
it's it's a very uh basic uh thing that
you're fighting you're fighting against
starvation you know what I mean so all
your problems like all your your little
problem will go away and focus only on
the problem that you're fighting of
starvation so
so it's not that the fasting that will
help you that will beat therapeutic for
you it's your when you break the fast
when you eat you will it will make you
appreciate life and how it will make you
realize how insignificant those little
problems that you have are same thing
when you're in a cold water immersion
you're fighting hypothermia I think it's
a little ironic as you're talking about
starvation and Pat had to have a little
bite of food right there yeah the
protein but if you believe you will
achieve yeah and I'm really glad that
you kind of
Revisited the conversation because you
said what's the next step with you GSP
and he said well you know I want to be
healthy and you're like no but like what
do you really want and the answer that
you gave was you want a coach you want
to help the youth and that coach uh I
don't have I don't think I have the
patient to be a good coach to to be
one-on-one at good coach yeah to pass
down pass down wisdom yes nowadays you
I remember when I wanted to learn Jiu
Jitsu I need to physically attempt a
class of jujitsu that's what that what
it was in my days when I first started
yeah nowadays a kid can take a cell
phone oh you want to learn another video
oh you look online so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]